for now though good evening and welcome
to tucker carlson happy columbus day
if you've been out celebrating the
discovery of america you may have missed
the first round
of amy coney barrett's confirmation
hearings so how were the hearings
well we watched in a word we put it this
way bizarre
bizarre for this reason almost none of
the attacks unbeared and of course there
are many of those
had anything to do with the job she is
trying to get
the supreme court exists only to
determine whether the laws that our
politicians write are consistent with
the constitution of the united
states that's why we have a supreme
court it's the only reason we have it
supreme court justices do not make laws
because they're not elected by voters
we don't let them legislate as a result
that's how democracy works only people
who are elected
get to make laws democrats would like to
change that system
they understand that congress is an
inherently small c
conservative body congress is never
going to change the country overnight in
some radical way because
voters don't want radical overnight
change they never do
so if you're going to have a revolution
if you're going to remake america you're
going to have to do it from above and
you're going to have to impose it on
people
and the left would like to use the
supreme court as their instrument to do
that a kind of
super congress with lifetime tenure
imagine
power like that there's nothing you
couldn't do
so once you understand that perspective
which is very much their perspective
today's hearings made sense democrats
spent hours talking about the 2009
obamacare law that was baffling at first
if you're interviewing someone for the
supreme court there's only one
relevant question about obamacare is it
constitutional
that's all they consider that's all
they're supposed to consider not how
they feel about the law now whether it
comports with their personal values not
whether their party supports it
is it constitutional and yet that was
one of the few things that democrats
didn't ask because they're not
interested in whether or not it's
constitutional
what they care about is power and
whether or not amy coney barrett will
diminish or enhance theirs so they
understand the supreme court purely in
political terms so not surprisingly
they conducted today's hearings like a
campaign rally
health care for millions of americans is
at stake
barked one finger wagging senator from
california
another democrat pointed to a photo of a
middle-aged woman called laura who
looked very unhappy
without obamacare the senator said laura
will be quote unable to afford the
treatments necessary for her to survive
in other words if any amy coney barrett
gets this job
it's curtains for laura democrat after
democrat made that very same point as
they so often have recently
obey us or many will die
you know that they are trying to push
through a justice who has been critical
of upholding the affordable care
act the effort to dismantle the law
continues
and they are asking the supreme court to
strike down
the affordable care act your nomination
is about the republican goal of
repealing the affordable care act the
obamacare
they seem to detest they are
deliberately defying the will of the
people
in their attempt to roll back the rights
and protections
provided under the affordable care act
well it sounds like obamacare is going
away if acb
gets on the court but it's not actually
and that's the amazing thing obamacare
isn't really at risk
there is no case currently pending
anywhere in this country before any
court in america
that would eliminate obamacare nor by
the way do we have any idea
how amy coney bear would rule in a case
like that were it to materialize which
again it hasn't
but most bewildering of all democrats
themselves have spent most of the past
two years publicly conceding that
obamacare
is a disaster six of the ten democrats
currently as of today sitting on the
judiciary committee in the senate that's
the same committee
that convened today to consider amy
coney barrett's nomination
six of the ten co-sponsored medicare for
all legislation
that legislation would have completely
abolished obamacare
along with all private health insurance
kamala harris is one of the people who
voted for that
amazing and yet there was kamala harris
today
warning us that the country will
collapse if amy coney barrett votes on a
hypothetical case
to destroy obamacare which she herself
voted to destroy
what it all seems kind of confusing
but think about it for a second and it
begins to make more sense
when you realize the goal is not to
preserve obamacare again
they voted to scrap obamacare the goal
is to undermine the legitimacy of our
systems and in this case of the supreme
court
so that joe biden and kamal harris can
pack the court full of partisan
democrats who will rubberstamp their
program
again it's about power oh
that's the key to the riddle when
confirmation hearings
become partisan political exercises they
make the supreme court itself seem like
a partisan political exercise
and that degrades the public's trust in
the court
and their support for our institutions
democrats know
that for the public to go along with
court packing they have to
delegitimize everything about the court
and the confirmation process
and so that's what they did today again
and again
lost in this hypocritical rush is the
legacy of ruth bader ginsburg
let me close by remembering her for a
minute in this unseemly charade
this is a charade when they say this is
a normal
judiciary committee hearing rushing a
judge
through this sham process they are
confident
that victory at the supreme court is now
within their grasp
if the senate confirms judge barrett
through
this hypocritical illegitimate
process yes judge i think this hearing
is a sham oh
ruth bader ginsburg because in a
democracy and you probably learned this
in civics class in a democracy you're
required
to obey the posthumous orders of
a dead person who was never elected okay
and when you don't it's a sham it's a
charade
never mind the fact that the senate is
of course by definition following
every constitutional procedure for
filling a supreme court vacancy
amy coney barrett isn't the outcome
though that democrats want
therefore our system they're telling us
is illegitimate
the irony of course is that it's donald
trump who's undermining our democratic
norms remember that they tell you that
at every turn
and yet it's not trump who tried to pack
the supreme court he could have tried
when
republicans can control congress he
didn't consider
pac of the supreme court now democrats
are planning to
and it's a familiar path hugo chavez
packed the supreme court of venezuela in
2004
erdogan did the same in turkey how'd
they do that how'd they get their
populations to go along with it
by claiming their judicial systems were
already illegitimate
sound familiar on saturday joe biden
stumbled through the same rehearsed line
you heard from kamala harris during the
debate last week
republicans have already packed the
court joe biden declared yes we've had
nine justices for more than 150 years
and yet
somehow without anyone noticing trump
packed the supreme court
he did the only
court packing going on right now is
going on with republicans
packing the court now it's not
constitutional what they're doing
they're the ones violating the
constitution says joe biden
so when i rewrite the constitution it'll
be fine
that's the predicate that's the setup
for what's coming next
joe biden knows republicans aren't
packing the court he also knows he can
repeat that lie with no consequences
whatsoever
because the media will never hold him to
account they want him to get away with
it
back in 2013 when it helped barack obama
a partisan operation called politifact
wrote
court packing has involved one branch of
government proposing to change the
structure of the courts
either expanding or decreasing the
number of justices
now republicans are not doing that it's
pretty simple they're not in favor of
doing that if they ever come out in
favor of doing it we will attack them
for doing it because we're not partisan
but of course you won't find a
politifact fact check of what joe biden
just said on saturday instead
our media actually rushed to perpetuate
his lives whatever it takes
whatever it takes so this weekend a
piece by the associated press
referred to court packing
non-sarcastically they weren't joking at
all as quote
de-politicizing the court
you increase the size of the court to
dilute the other side's
power you pack it full of partisans who
do your bidding
and that's de-politicizing it here's how
the ap put it quote
montana senate candidate steve bullock
said that if coney barrett was confirmed
he would be open to measures to
de-politicize the court
including adding judges to the bench
practice critics have dubbed packing the
court
yet no not critics scholars
historians politicians
ruth bader ginsburg herself every person
in america
referred to court packing as court
packing up until two weeks ago
right it's hard to believe that line
made it into print but it did court
packing is just de-politicizing the
court now
you'll probably see that definition
formalized in the ap's next woke style
guide next to
their entries on undocumented shoppers
and peaceful riots
fundamentally though the ap is on to
something inadvertently many judges
and justices in this country are
obviously political they have a lot of
power too much power
more power than any individual should
have power in this country should reside
with the electorate people who are
elected should have the most power not
people who are appointed
unelected judges shouldn't be deciding
issues like abortion immigration policy
for the entire country
but they are the solution of that is not
to
embrace more politics in your judicial
branch though it's to recognize the
proper role of the courts to de-escalate
a little bit to bring us
a little closer to sanity in a brief
moment toward the end of today's hearing
in her opening statement amy coney
barrett tried to do exactly that watch
courts have a vital responsibility to
the rule of law which is critical to a
free society
but courts are not designed to solve
every problem
or right every wrong in our public life
the policy decisions and value judgments
of government
must be made by the political branches
elected by and accountable to the people
the public should not expect courts to
do so and courts
should not try so these hearings of amy
coney barrett will continue for the next
couple of days
barring some really dramatic development
that it's hard even to imagine
it does seem very likely that she'll be
confirmed in the end so there's not a
lot of drama at least as of tonight
surrounding
her nomination what happens to the
supreme court itself
however is very much in doubt and along
with it our country